while the weather has been so
comfortable the last few days but
all good things come to an end brian
denise triple digits on the horizon for
us a really good reminder to keep an eye
for heat
dangers christian costar is joining us
live in studio he's got some tips for
medical experts to avoid
a trip to the er that's right brian and
denise well it may seem like common
sense but if you're a local or just
visiting
you might want to pay close attention
basic rule rule number one
is to stay hydrated many people tend to
forget that that's what the team at the
american medical response
recommended they stress the importance
of drinking plenty of water
applying sunscreen and wearing clothing
that protects your arms and legs as well
as your face
now the dangerous heat can cause a
sunburn within minutes
some signs to watch out for dizziness
vomiting or
confusion they say the summertime is
their busiest time of the year with a
28 increase in heat related emergency
calls
but the heat can also lead to other
dangers that many people
tend to ignore people want to get into
the pool
they want to you know cool off whatever
they need to do so we're going to also
stress when it comes to water
and make sure you're aware of what's
going on in the water especially with
our little ones
they're so excited to get into the pool
so we really do stress
safety devices and if you do have a pool
at home
make sure those gates are locked with
pools always busy during the summer
leslie shaffer with the
amr recommends taking a swim class they
never hurt it could
really be a life or death decision in
the future and of course always call
9-1-1
in case of an emergency also as coveted
restrictions roll back and more people
head outside
it's a good reminder that alcohol does
not count for hydrating yourself
amr recommends a cup of water along with
that drink that you get at the bar
christian concedes 8 news now kristen
thank you so we asked on twitter if
you're local
does the heat bother you or by now are
you just used to it
here are the numbers 31 percent said
yeah i'm bothered by this heat
69 saying i've gotten used to it